and so it's on months of debate about
the future of our relationship with
Europe now over the course of this
campaign you're going to hear all sorts
of claims and counterclaims and even the
odd bit of dodgy information so this
calls for a survival guide how to
navigate your way through the brexit
campaign and so here are the three big
rules first but where the big eye
catching catch all numbers let's start
with one you've probably already heard
from the remaining camp and that is the
idea that if we left the EU 3,000 pounds
per household would be lost three
million jobs would be at risk according
to their research sounds like a lot
doesn't it but when you dig into the
numbers you find that that 3,000 pounds
is the total economic activity
associated with EU trade no one even the
biggest pessimist expects that to
disappear overnight but this isn't the
only fishy claim out there another one
you've probably heard from the leaf
campaign is the idea that EU membership
cost the UK a whopping 20 billion pounds
a year again sounds like a lot doesn't
it but when you dig into the actual
research you find that first of all 20
billion is kind of overstating it should
be closer to 17 point nine billion
second of all when you account for all
the money coming back from the EU to the
UK the net cost of EU membership is
actually about eight point four billion
pounds still not to be sniffed at but
nowhere near as much as they claim so
survival rule number one but where the
big numbers rule number two but where
the small numbers to my particular
bugbear here are all those job losses
claims you know the kind of thing HSBC
saying a thousand jobs are going to go
over to France you want do a bank
reconsidering whether their headquarters
are going to be here in the UK an Airbus
thinking about kind of the same thing
now the precedent suggests that those
threats don't normally get followed
through but on the other side of things
look out for all of those small numbers
about the costs of EU membership you've
got financial regulations environmental
rules crd for solvency too it's very
easy to get blinded by all of this but
don't miss the wood for the trees the
big picture is that even if the UK
became like
way it would still have to adopt almost
ninety-five percent of those regulations
which brings me to rule number three
what's the alternative to coin a phrase
what's the road map neither side in the
brexit debate seems very keen on
explaining precisely what kind of a deal
we'd have if we left will we be like
Norway would we be like Canada that has
an enormous bearing on the costs and
indeed the benefit of brexit but instead
both sides so far seem far more keen on
focusing less on the facts and more on
the fear but don't worry the best
survival tip of all is to ignore all the
emotional stuff and concentrate on the
details after all this is a crucial fork
in Britain's political road does it stay
in the fold or sort off in a totally
different direction at Conway Sky News